i think joel kinnaman or a joel kinnaman
type probably joe cannon
is going to play craven the hunter in
the third spider-man could almost see
norman osborne being an ally to peter
parker helping him
kind of evade craven the hunter i feel
like chameleon is pulling the strings
three two one wish lap parties
and i heard what party
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars spider-man
3 is looking at
joel kinnaman for a mystery role but hey
no mystery is too mysterious for nerds
to
crave over or get us bored
of ah comedy on with these puns
don't click away please this is rogue
theory the podcast that brings you the
wildest nerdy hot takes on the topics
you can't stop
arguing over i'm eric boss and with me
today
to pitch rogue theories are america's
favorite uncle tommy bechtold
hello you're grounded just kidding there
are no rules at uncle tom's house
you're not my dad you're just his
brother uh also joining us
i raised you i raised you when your
parents died in that barn accident
accident
okay that barn on purpose
also joining us uh writer journalist and
cosplayer laura siriqual welcome to new
rock stars hi guys i'm so excited to be
here and hi huncle tommy
hi proud of you and uh rounding out the
panel
hunter of the most dangerous game that
being trader joe's employees who haven't
restocked the apples
off-screen producers zach huddleston
hello top three apples i got nvs
i got honey crisps and i got pink's
crisps
wow yeah honey crisps so that's a good
one i have a granny smith guy myself
always have been ah your uncle would be
into it granny wouldn't you
that's right that mean yeah
my browser i don't use expressvpn when
zack's watching my searches
hey that's for later in the episode
let's move on to our first topic
casting reports for the upcoming
spider-man 3 title still
unknown though we are getting some
reports that it might be homesick
maybe homespun maybe where a mask can
stay home subliminal messages that are
actually helping
save everyone's lives these reports are
suggesting that sony and marvel are
looking to cast
a joel kinnaman type with other reports
saying that they might just be looking
at joel kinneman himself
you know maybe the gruff fella from
suicide squad and altered carbon will
finally get his marvel debut
or maybe like for many actors the role
will go to someone less talented who
looks exactly like him
so based on what we know about the
spider-man narrative and franchise so
far
i wanna know from you guys who tells us
about the mystery plot of the next
spider-man film
what character are they looking to fill
zach why don't you go first
okay thank you eric and i just want to
point out we've seen
joel kidman's one of those guys whose
name you might not know but he's been in
a lot of stuff
like if you watched the killing altered
carbon obviously the suicide squad he's
going to be in the next suicide squad
what a lot of people maybe don't realize
about him because he's almost always
talking with an
american accent is that he's a swedish
fellow
like those skarsgards right like he's
he's from scandinavia
and you know what accent sounds kind of
similar to scandinavian
russian my man's playing craven
okay at least one uh iteration in the
comics
is russian right um and instead of
having
um matthew mcconaughey do it terrible or
jason momoa do a terrible russian accent
why not get somebody closer to that part
of the world right sure yeah i think
i think joel kinnaman or a joel kinnaman
type probably joe cannon
is going to play craven the hunter in
the third spider-man right
and i think sony really wants craven to
be this next villain not only because
he's a great
spider-man villain we haven't seen in
any film version yet
but he gives them a overall
spumcy villain that can travel between
their properties
right craven can hunt down venom he can
show up
uh hunting down dr morbius right like
all kinds of opportunities he could be a
part of the sinister six
he can fight the sinister six right like
a really powerful chess piece on the
splumpsy
chessboard ooh i i do love that idea
zack and like
craven the hunter seems definitely like
the one
they're headed towards either in this
next film or some future film
you know what's interesting is like when
you re-watch the mark webb
amazing spider-man 2 they had that kind
of post-credit thing where they're like
here are the sinister six designs and
all of our titles
and like while it seems like that was a
scrapped plan
yeah we had vulture come up in the next
spider-man live-action movie we saw
so yeah i think craven the hunter who
has also teased in that it's gotta be on
sony's wishlist
and i could definitely definitely see uh
uh joel kidman playing that like just
seeing that guy carry a rifle
it's just so natural you know like you
wanna see him patrolling some urban
uh streets and like uh scoping out some
areas it's just like his natural
instinct i think to do that yeah
and you could see like especially the
route they've been going with their
villains of like very
grounded realistic right like no giant
human lizards
so far in the you know spumsy right
and so like he would totally fit in
there just being like
a vaguely eastern european questionable
like
you know cast member from hostile or
something like that who like
wanders into peter parker's new york
looking to
um you know hunt him down both because
he's the super powered creature
and maybe there's some big money behind
it which maybe one of the other theories
will cut
cover but uh yeah i think like it's a
definite he makes a lot of sense maybe
more sense than some of the other names
people have thrown out both
for the villain and for the actor who
would play the villain yeah
um well zach to decide how many uh
sparkle bucks the sparkle books are back
folks
uh you're going to get um i feel like
i'm gonna bring in a guest here to
decide
who or how many you get and i'm gonna
let our friend baby groot decide
so how many sparkle bucks is off screen
zack
and our video just got flagged for deep
hydrisation for unlicensed
music uh no what that means is uh you
get
one uh sparta oh yeah
i think what you meant to say there eric
is um i get
i am groot worth of sparkle bugs that's
that's fair
i i'm translating for him but that is
technically what he said
and to me one it's weird because the
words for groot for one and 11 are very
similar
uh but i'm gonna round down to one uh
just because you you kind of gave too
much of an opportunity to
your co-panelist to say some of the
other theories might be might cover this
this is uh uh grab the gold my friend
it's
it rewards greed and so you get just one
okay well on my end fittingly eric that
turns into a
uh can of sardines okay uh and now these
are sardines in water i usually prefer
the sardines in oil
don't knock them till you try them folks
put this on some toast okay and you're
eating good
sorry beans yeah and if you're a
shrunken down character in a cartoon you
can use that to sleep in at the end of
the night
oh he's right he's right you just peel
the little foil back as
a blanket that's right he gets your nice
little space blanket really sharp that
smells like rotting fish
uh all right laura uh it's your turn who
do you think joel kidman's gonna be
playing in this next spider-man film
so everyone's like oh craven craven
craven but craven has a half brother
and his half brother is a com is
chameleon who dimitri
smear the yolk who we've seen already
um played by newmar akar so chameleon
is a shape shifter so i have a feeling
either he's a squirrel or
the technology that mysterio took that
guy
took it to kind of become anyone
because you know it's the technology
like oh it we could trick
anything can happen so i feel like
chameleon is pulling the strings
yeah maybe kraven's gonna show up but
his half-brother is pulling the strings
and could be anyone and if you said that
oh hey
he could be in venom's world you know
what communion could be venom
like boom like just the character and
like become that person
so he could be used in multiple
universes and we don't need to use
newman a car because it could be a
disguise
like the for the long run so
i feel like we're gonna see because he's
never been used before he's never been
in live action so i feel like
chameleon's a good choice
to be the person behind the string like
pulling all the strings
um so my take is that chameleon
is going to be pushing for peter parker
to be hunted laura you bring up a really
good point because at the end of far
from home
uh we learned like what mysterio's
operation really was all about and we
learned what like fury and hill's
operation was all about and leftover was
just this
other operative who was with them and we
don't know whose side he was on whether
he was part of
whether he's like just another team fury
because it's not really shield anymore
it's his own kind of weird group that i
are we to assume all of those people
were scrolls
or like someone had an another uh agenda
there
and i think there there is something to
that guy it'd be a bit of a bummer for
neumann akar
to like have to be like ah you'll be in
one part of this movie
hey he's gotten some work he was in
aladdin the live action aladdin's and
some other stuff
but like if he could be one of the many
identities that the chameleon plays
yeah like when when peter looked at him
with edith
it said classified that's right it
totally did
i forgot about that so hey he could be
i'm just saying he could be
one of the main villains and we've been
we've been like talking about the other
side villains
yeah i i agree that's very interesting
all right uh baby groot
i i know you're from guardians of galaxy
vol 2 and your character has aged to a
larger age range and this is
a piece of merch that's specific to one
movie and not the overall franchise
but what do you think of laura's theory
that's like the same song that used last
time and we've been
we've been flagged again flagged once
again all right so
uh baby groot has awarded you uh
one sparkle book but then another one
because he brought up an
easter egg from a recent videos and this
channel is all about
easter eggs that you might have
forgotten about for movies so you are
awarded to
roggy sparkle bucks it turned into
because of baby groot it's related to
jeff goldblum looking sexy he was part
of the guardians of the galaxy too
so i made it relate to him he was
he was yeah didn't he show up at the end
or was he in rack
yeah he was in like the po the credits
dancing setting up ragnarok yeah
but that was right grand master that's
definitely worth two sparkle bucks at
least
tommy who do you think joel kidman could
be playing in spiderman three i believe
that
joel kinnaman is going to play a
large looming villain father figure
mentor nemesis occasional teammate
of spider-man uh he is going to play
none other than norman osborne he's
going to play
specifically uh he's going to play the
norman osborne from the
ultimate marvel baseball yeah
he's a little more like techy and cool
he's not quite this like
he's not as old he's not his like he's
not he's not quite the like
far away nemesis of like he's got 40
years on peter parker
he's a little bit younger and i think
that that's going to introduce a younger
harry osborn as well who's going to be
like a 16 year old is going to look up
to peter parker
a lot to kind of nurture that dynamic
between them so i could see him being
uh and also the ultimate um ultimate
marvel
norman osborne works very intimately
with shield so it still ties him
into the larger mcu if they want to use
that character in a like an avengers
movie if spider-man
continues through the mcu obviously so i
think i could see him kind of being like
a
single father in his early 40s raising a
16 year old
kind of like a cooler more i guess
like whereas like willem dafoe was like
a hero to peter parker like this is a
rich guy who has a massive company
and is like very distant from harry he's
gonna be a more hands-on father i don't
even know if he'll become green goblin
in this movie you know i could see him
just establishing as the norman osborne
community leader
you know pillar of uh pillar of the
community version
uh and then eventually turning into a
green uh evolving into the green goblin
in a later film
in that in that universe that's really
interesting tommy so do you think
uh the antagonist of this movie might
not be green goblin that like
or norman osborne norman osborne could
be like this background figure the way
like
colson was and then someone else's or i
could see it being
a i could see them doing the movie i
feel like they really want to do craven
the hunter as the bad guy in this movie
but i could see them establishing craven
the hunter and i could almost see
norman osborne being an ally to peter
parker helping
him kind of evade craven the hunter
uh and then ultimately simultaneously in
the film testing the super soldier serum
that he's
working on shield because that's i mean
that's the marvel storyline the ultimate
marvel storyline is that he's developing
the super
soldier serum for uh for shield and
testing it out
ultimately one of those tests goes wrong
and he becomes the green goblin
maybe in a post-credits scene setting up
a future bell or maybe at the very end
of the movie but i don't see him being
the main bad guy
throughout the course of the film no
yeah um tommy you bring up some really
interesting points and i think what i
personally will see what groot has to
say but what i
like about it is that uh every other
time we've seen norman osborne in the
film
he just appears in one film and he's
done whereas norman osborne is a very
important character to marvel comics and
you're right
he's very important like leader within
shield within certain eras of comics
uh and he keeps coming back again and
again in different ways and it would be
a shame
just to have him immediately turn to
green goblin and immediately be defeated
so to have a movie that just like sets
him up uh and then he can be like a
recurring character in the mcu or the
sony side of things
from there forward is very interesting
but what do you say about it
that might actually get flagged because
uh come a little bit closer
uh they definitely don't want that uh
being used without their permission so i
just want to point out how eric has
become
like one of those villains who's like a
ventriloquist who's like yeah i don't
want to kill you but the dog
does one of those villains
i feel like that's a common trope i've
seen a million ventriloquist
movie yeah it's kind of a sub genre now
right if i had a nickel for every time
i've seen a
guy murder someone and blame it on his
ventriloquist dummy i'll tell you
it's it's a weird loophole in like us um
sixth amendment law you know like you
can't prosecute someone
if they could say because we don't want
to acknowledge whether or not magic
exists in the context that's
true it's just a thing it's just a weird
thing uh so tommy uh groot awards you
two uh norman osborne green sparkle
bucks
but zach uh because both of the other
panelists acknowledged your theory
as a craven uh you get another sparkle
book
so uh tommy gets two zack gets another
one that's crazy those sparkle bucks
actually transported into practical
things i think they knew that i needed
them it's a uh
vita fusion men's uh gummy vitamins for
adult men that are afraid to swallow
pills and then a uh
a nature made uh fish oil capsules that
are uh running low so
time for me to go to speaking of fish
oil on my end
eric that bonus burger [ __ ] turned into
a can of tuna maybe
yeah maybe i could uh zach i'll mail you
some fish oil capsules you could break
them open into your sardines and get
that garbage water out of there put them
in the oil where they belong
yeah just hide it in your tuna sandwich
and eat it like how you have to give
your dog pills you hide it in bread yes
it works every time all right i want to
hear
these pitches back in tweet forms uh
zach
give us to give it to us in a tweet okay
spider-man home invasion i know homesick
is going around but i like home invasion
better
spider-man home invasion kinnaman type
more like
craven man type
it's pretty compact
[Laughter]
all right laura what's your tweet
spiderman
home at last
uh ah i'm trying to think of john cena
i'm thinking of john cena for some
reason
[Laughter]
to pitch to john cena as my as my
spider-man character it's it's a it's a
bold move she used the scene option
some would argue joel john cena could be
a jewel kinnaman type i don't know yeah
you totally could we're like suicide
squad the co-star
all right tommy what's your tweet okay
mine is
uh off the top of my head joe kinnaman
as norman osborne
that's more exciting than wizard of oz
i hope i don't get the internet scorn my
favorite star trek actor is
michael dorn star trek it's almost like
you know what our next topic is
i have no idea i've never briefed on
this i just want you to do all my poems
all right uh let us know in the comments
below which version of spider-man 3
you want to see do you want to see all
of these because
i feel like all three of these theories
are pretty compatible with each other
uh they could totally work within one
movie maybe cooperation is the answer
all right before we continue we want to
thank some people who helped us make
this show starting with our friends at
keeps so thank you to keeps for helping
make this episode two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
losing your hair can be a bummer
with keeps it's easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost
of your local pharmacy uh you don't have
to go to your doctor's office with keeps
you can do it all from home you meet
with the doctor online and they ship the
treatment right to
your home and find out why keep says
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors and nearly 100 000 men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication you see with that
stat
hopefully we're reassuring many of you a
hundred thousand other men out there
are also losing their hair it's probably
even more than that you're not alone
you're not alone
don't feel bad it happens to everyone
it's called aging and
you shouldn't feel guilty about it but
if you do keeps us here to help you
and if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com rogue theory to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com theory we also wanna thank our
friends at bespoke post for sponsoring
this episode
i always like getting deliveries whether
they're things i ordered online or
another care package for my prison
pen pal um or um legal paperwork
pertaining to the will
and testament of my parents which is not
fun paperwork to get but
it's something that people our age are
going through
once a month my mailbox is even more
exciting though because
bespoke post sends me a box of awesome
and that will clear any bad thoughts you
have about any other mail you get
so bespoke sends guys only the best
stuff every month no matter what you're
into box of awesome has you covered
from style and grooming goods to bar
wear cooking tools outdoor gear
box of awesome has carefully built
collections for every part of your life
i recently got the coast box which came
with a great summary
shirt and a waterproof beach wallet so i
have
multiple kinds of wallets now they get
to use so but when i want to take my
wallet to the beach
so that when i'm sneaking booze there
and then a cop says you're not supposed
to be drinking booze on the beach i
could say at least i'm 21 sir
and he goes really i'm not surprised
because you look
way older than that he's one of the
commenters on this channel
bespoke post also has multiple booze
themed boxes including
mixed box that has vixens to make a
moscow mule
her spicy margarita again what i'm
drinking
on the beach doesn't matter what time of
year it is
or how dangerous it is to do to get
started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com to pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories it's free to sign up and you
can skip a month or cancel
anytime each box only costs 45 bucks but
has over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
they should just call these treasure
boxes because they're filled
with treasure get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com and enter the code rogue
at checkout that's box of awesome dot
com
code rogue for 20 off your first box
and we also want to thank our friends at
expressvpn
as tommy mentioned earlier this episode
sometimes our online research for new
rockstars videos takes us to some
questionable
directions that we don't have in our
internet search history because we're
doing it
for academic reasons and academic only
that we do not mix business with
pleasure when we're on company time
otherwise um uh still alive fema will
hunt us down
uh worse than joel kinnaman ever could
it is times like these
when it doesn't matter what mode you use
or how many times you clear your
browsing history your internet service
provider can still see
every site you have visited it's a scary
scary world
and that is why whether you are at home
or you are at work or
both as we are now we use expressvpn
so expressvpn is an app that reroutes
your internet connection through their
secure servers
so your isp can't see the sites you
visit
expressvpn keeps all your information
secure by encrypting 100
of your data with the most powerful
encryption available
it runs seamlessly in the background
just tap one button and you're protected
and it's available on all your devices
phones computers smart tvs
uh futuristic things that uh future
versions of yourself gave you and said
use this so they can't track you they
can still track you on those he was
tricking you
as all future versions of me tend to do
protect your online identity today with
the vpn rated number one by cnet and
wired visit my exclusive link
expressvpn.com
rogue and you can get an extra three
months free on a one-year package
that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
rogue expressvpn.comrogue to learn more
we now move on to our discord rogue
theory we do this every week we play a
game of rogue theory with our patrons on
new rockstars discord
this week we had some patrons pitch
theories about the third season of
umbrella academy now that the second
season
is out in the world and people are
watching it we had some fun theories
this week from danny x
and e vulgar our winner this week was
ron weasley
uh and if you haven't seen the full
season of umbrella academy yet
uh skip to this time but uh zach you had
some thoughts on ron weasley's theory
what did you think about it
yes as somebody who just finished season
two and thoroughly enjoyed it i really
all three of the theories are really
good and with the show that is so
nuts like umbrella academy it really
lends itself to great
like jumping in time and all over the
place uh kind of theories but um ron
weasley had some great ones where like
well not to spoil season two too much
but something that's hinted at in the
very last seconds of season two
right has a big impact over season three
and there's kind of parallels between
two different groups
that's the vaguest possible description
i could give but it was
good uh well thank you to everyone who
submitted this week we'll do this again
and
you can play to have your theory read on
an episode of rogue theory
just by becoming a patron at any level
of new rock stars and you can join our
discord you have to be 18 years old or
older
sorry it's just something we do to
protect all the people we're
we're not camp counselors here uh so
uh let's move on to our next topic news
came out this week that paramount
is both prioritizing another star trek
film
and also kind of stuck between three
options that have been in development
for years
there is a fourth film in the chris pine
jj abrams
the kelvin timeline as it's known uh
featuring a return
of kirk's father played by chris
hemsworth remember that i remember that
prologue there was a reboot film penned
by legion and fargo writer noah holly
and a strange one-off directed by
quentin tarantino
which he said was based on the original
series episode that was set in a 1930s
gangster planet
i want you three to pitch me on which of
those proposed star trek films you would
most want to see and why
tommy why don't you go first this time
baby you know
the only star trek that i need to see is
based on a piece of the action
from star trek the original series
quentin tarantino's
gangster star trek you got to be kidding
me chicago mobsters
mixing with my star trek friends give it
all to me
what does tarantino know how to do he
knows how to create
bad guys that you love he knows how to
create people
that do despicable things but you still
kind of love them
what is america's obsession with mafia
people
they're bad guys they do despicable
things but we still kind of love them
why do we watch scorsese movies why do i
cheer on robert de niro and the irishman
as he kills people that may have
families for all we know nice people
people that just want to sell flowers
people that just want to own a bakery
next to another bakery that's mafia
controlled
plugged in the head and there i am
clapping along give me tarantino
making these star trek gangsters do
despicable things
rated pg-13 so close to r three f words
max
and then give me fresh cast new people i
don't need chris pine back
send him to wonder woman forever give me
a new captain kirk you know
maybe ricky gervais plays captain kirk i
don't know he's got the hair for it
doesn't he
he's getting old though uh let me get
back on track here i need it to be
tarantino
america needs it to be tarantino we need
movies full of hope and if you remember
remember the way that episode ends kirk
essentially tricks
the mafia family the the opposing mafia
families
into working together uh uh because
they'll keep
and giving the federation a piece of the
action
uh but he leaves uh technology
on their planet so that they can learn
how to use federation communicators so
like it is uh it's a total power
struggle power grab
it's a rags to riches story and it's
what this world needs right now
as we all struggle through the pandemic
i rest my case
all right tommy i'm going to let baby
groot weigh in on this
that's all he had to say um shut up
shut up okay i'm sorry you just he you
can't stop talking
uh groot awards you won just because
um while we would love to see quentin
tarantino's take on anything
that episode of star trek so sucked
and i uh i don't want to see that world
i want to see
quentin tarantino or write his write his
original stories i don't want to see his
take
on a genre franchise uh i i love quentin
tarantino one of my favorite directors i
don't need to see him do star trek at
all okay and that sparkle book came
through into my screen as i how dare you
insult queen tarantino no
just kidding it came up as a
a bottle of night shred from immuno subs
this bottle of nitride was supposed to
come in seven to ten business days but
took over a month but they sent me an
apology
in a 25 off coupon for some sort of beet
formula
as if i need to take beets in a
formulaic method
you eat them you boil them you put them
in a salad beets are pretty simple you
could juice them if you want
anyway it's an immunosupps yeah order
them if you want but don't expect them
in
10 business days all right um laura
thanks a lot to keep this machine
running
all right okay so everyone loves fargo
everyone loved the new the the fargo
that they had on fx
everyone loved legion so what's
that's not bad it's not a bad idea to
have him do
a new star trek so star trek is about
the future and how we want hope for the
future
in this dystopian world and all that
stuff so
the idea that he had before
corona happened was a pandemic
happening in space where deadly virus is
happening
so his idea is to of course like they're
gonna
figure out a way to solve it with um
with new characters and everything
so that's hopeful for us guys we're in a
pandemic
i'm talking to you through here instead
of the studio so
in in the world of star trek it would be
great to have a solution as well like oh
no there's lost hope it's because it's
happening in the world
but then you know in the end hope
prevails
and his new characters i'm hoping it
will be canon
uh following um my favorite john luke
picard
um because he wants some new characters
and news stories so
if he were to do a new story then why
not to
have a little bit of picard and some of
the other lovable characters like
janeway because of the same age and same
timeline yeah
um in the calvin universe so that's my
take on what he's gonna have planned
and the hope that we have it's on hold
right now but once it starts going i
feel like
it's gonna be a hopeful end just like
hopefully this pandemic will have a
hopeful end
and that's my that's my take um laura
what i really like about your take is
like
when when i heard that they might have
been leaning away from noah holly doing
the
the pandemic version i was really bummed
out because like
yes it's a dark thing that we're all
going through but you are right this is
something we are all going through
and i would hate that like studios are
now afraid to do
certain stories just because they remind
people of our lives if anything
that's what we want like uh yes some
movies are escapism but
movies are also designed to reflect back
our world and teach us new ways to
process our world
and movies that are just pure escapism
that's why i hate when people are like
in the comments they're like
why are you reminding me of certain
things like i watch new rockstars videos
to escape it's like
then you are not truly understanding
anything you watch on tv or film
because every writer isn't trying to
just get you to forget about your life
it's trying to get you to reframe and
process your life
so i i really really hope that like this
doesn't
decrease the type of viral stories
because like we need to
learn from what's happening right now we
need to uh learn like how not to make
the mistakes
that we're making and we need to see
what happens when our fictional
characters
go through the heightened versions of
this or sci-fi versions of this
so i love that idea but again it comes
down
to what groot has to say
[Applause]
it's like you have two versions of
things you could say
and i think it's like uh the old woody
thing like there's a snake in my boot
like he's kind of running out of juice
uh we've had that for quite a few years
but uh groot gives you two sparkle bugs
wow and that will turn into
what is this john luke the card in the
in
in in the bobble head form and wait
what's this
it's a photo of eric telling me
wait let me see if you guys can see it
it's a photo telling me to give me
[Music]
that was sneaky you're gonna lose one
for that
you lose one and you lose your photo for
me it's going back in the stock
so nice try we we don't allow uh
cheating here and i'm not afraid
i am not afraid to drop the law um
but uh but still very interesting uh
take laura and i and i hope that we're
able to see no holly's vision
at some point uh zach what is your
theory first off i want to say i love
laura's pandering there
pandemic more like pandordemic no
okay uh all right okay
uh so so my pitch i think is is um
maybe the most logical one and that's
just give us
a fourth chris pines zachary quinto
um jj abrams broad
kelvin universe movie okay i we got
three
and i've enjoyed those i think maybe oh
they've
maybe been a little bit diminishing
returns um or maybe they peaked with the
second one into darkness a little bit i
mean the fan base is
is a little torn there but i've really
enjoyed them i think that's
a great cast i've i've liked the
direction they've taken it
um and they haven't had a chance to like
wrap that series up
right and i think um though historically
star trek movies don't usually wrap
things up right they keep making them
forever until the cast dies
but um i i would or until they no longer
make any money but
i would like that like if if they're
able to pull this off and i know they're
gonna have to open up the bank to pay
chris hemsworth and the rest of that
cast but
like do it right because like oh to come
back to papa kirk
after we kind of started with him right
like really kind of close the loop and
tell a full story with the kelvin
universe
i would love that i think that could be
like a really powerful story to tell
i also think it gives them the
opportunity um you know star trek tv
continues to do good stuff
uh cbs all access and picard all this
kind of stuff right like
and there's this um strange new world
show
uh possibly coming down the pipeline it
gives them the chance the the kelvin
timeline has not directly connected to
any active tv
properties yet right this gives them the
opportunity maybe to do that right to
kind of like
while completing their story to also
kind of subtly hand off the baton
maybe to be continued on some kind of
streaming show or another film franchise
or something like that uh very
interesting zack i i'm with you
i watched all of those kelvin timeline
movies i watched them opening weekend
in the theater i was disappointed by the
third one but i'd be willing to watch a
fourth one
groot what do you think
you have like three things you can say
what do you mean okay this is not
baby groot's fault it's your fault eric
you can't rely on
a magic eight ball to make all your
decisions okay
i i defer responsibility whenever i can
and uh groot gave you well that's the
thing he said he wanted to give you
three but because he had to call me out
i'm deducting two
and you just get one wow
you know what you know what you're
you're one
becomes three okay
and that's like one thing it's got three
cans in it
yeah too hard for everybody if i if i
recognize that green hue
those are packed in oil oh yeah
yeah oh yeah all right
uh it seems like we are tied in our
sparkle buck counts but it is
anyone's game as we move on to rogue
questions are we
ready yes yes all right let's do it
uh question one the conjuring director
james wan
is making a knight rider movie what
would you like your talking car to be
able to do
uh for me i would like that my talking
car to
uh heal me the old wounds i had of
learning to drive
with my parents i would like to have my
parents voices complimenting me on
how good of a driver i've become like if
i do a nice turn they're like wow
tom real control of the vehicle that's
really nice you seem to be in control
there you're definitely mature enough to
have a car
and drive after 9 pm and it wouldn't
panic and it wouldn't talk on its cell
phone when i was driving to my road test
psyching me out as i was driving down
the highway and then they wouldn't get
divorced because they'd be stuck in my
car forever
so i'm a meat freak so i i
do eat in my car and i spill a lot of
like crap on
like when i eat and like i'm like oh i
have to vacuum it later
i want the car to clean itself i want it
to be like oh you spilled something
it clean it's clean it's like i don't
need to worry about and i could be like
eating a hot dog and it all splatters
and it's like clean so i want it to
to like i want to be able to eat and not
gain weight but also to like have it be
clean
that does sound like a dream car for
sure
mine's simple i just want mine to be
able to tell me
when a warning light is serious or not
serious because you know
yeah they all light up and sometimes
it's just like oh
one tire's a little low another times
like your car's about to blow up
i just want a car that tells me what to
take seriously i'm not messing around
zach you need to go in and get serviced
this is
not the drill this time your car is
actually on fire
uh zach gets the point on that one
because i think we can all relate yep
yeah yeah
and it's probably another can of tuna um
question two
cardi b's new song wap or wap
has become a viral sensation
but what is the nerdiest thing the
acronym wap could stand for
i'll go first if everyone's feeling a
little shy it stands for wario ass [ __ ]
that's a that looks very normal and is
super enjoyable but you realize when you
get in there it's evil
and is the opposite of what you thought
it was going to be so yeah you want to
watch out for wario ass
guys
[Laughter]
my mom
[Music]
across planets because we were talking
about star trek oh
yeah nice but now i'm like
oh like we're up in the crossbar
i'm kidding
tommy what have you done to the show i
know mom you what the heck man
i'm sorry guys sorry my fault my fault
yeah we broke the damn
cross planets because we were talking
about what we're talking about
okay both great i was gonna go with um
mine is uh wakanda always provides
which is the wakanda based universal
basic income
uh they got enough money in that magic
mountain to pay everybody monthly
um or of course uh wakanda
yes
uh tommy for pulling us down to the
gutter with you you get the point for
that one
oh great and it becomes um probiotics
from cultural
not a sponsor of the show uh and our
third
and final rogue question a japanese
company has developed a socially distant
drive-in
haunted house where your car gets
sprayed with blood
whoa uh what is the creepiest thing that
could happen in a drive-through
haunted house if i were to go through a
drive-through
haunted house i don't know how political
we're allowed to say but if i were to
see
trump pence signs everywhere driving in
the neighborhood
with a whole bunch of like trump tense
signs everything oh yeah
and like the southern kind of things
i'll be like yes turn around
oh no i got off i got off interstate 10
in uh florida panhandle suburb
i gotta turn around i'm like that's
really nice turn around
yes that's a good one i think
mine would be this kind of calls back to
uh laura's first
rogue question answer mine would be um
the grumpy
or grumpier old men move if you take a
dead fish and you throw it in somebody's
car
and then like you get the ghost of a
dead fish smell hunting your car
for months and months says the guy who
has a fish can
yeah yeah that's right
yes uh yeah for me the scariest thing
that could happen in a drive-through
haunted house would just be it becomes a
functioning car wash because those are
terrifying
the assault that your car takes as they
recklessly
spray water at you out of cannons and
then slam
chamois cloths all over it there's
nothing more claustrophobic and
terrifying to me
than the three minutes of car cleansing
that takes place in a car wash so
and uh i assume you haven't seen the
final destination
scene that is set at a car wash do you
just hate the normal car wash experience
i to me every car wash is a final
destination because i always attended my
car afterwards
you go through a lot of cars uh well the
winner of that point
is gonna go to laura because i agree
that for me would be the most
frightening surroundings yeah
well that evens our scores what have i
done giving everyone points making it
even well i like to think all of us are
winners today um
so whatever wish you might have had in
your head uh think on it for a second
we're all going to uh yell it into the
screen at the same time
uh and then hopefully they'll all come
true but it has to be at the same time
all right everyone got your wish in your
head all right here we go
three two one wish me luck
and i heard what party
yeah that was that was my fun
lance is always work working for the web
um
all right well that is this episode
of rogue theory i want to thank our
guest this has been so much fun
uh tommy beck told america's uncle
uh laura sierra cool once again welcome
to the rockstar so glad we could get you
on
it's been a delight and off-screen
producers that caused it
always a pleasure admiral boss
uh and don't forget to subscribe to the
rogue theory podcast feed
stay tuned for the youtube channel for
this and other shows
we got a week full of very exciting dc
related content we're breaking down
man of steel tomorrow for tomorrow's
video definitely want to check that out
uh be sure to follow me on twitter at
eavos follow the channel at new
rockstars
always having great infographics and
stuff that's fun to share and debate
about on there
see you next week everyone bye
[Music]
you